the man behind deus ex and the original  system shock is joining other side  entertainment to lead development on  System Shock 3 Warren Spector will leave  his teaching position at UT Austin in  order to join the developer full-time  Specter says he loves teaching but he  couldn't turn down the opportunity to  work on another system shock game when  the opportunity to have a bigger role in  bringing underworld ascendant to life as  well as playing in the system shock  universe once again helping to bring  these games to a 21st century audience I  just couldn't say no said members of  other side of works with Spector in the  past on games like System Shock the  Ultima Underworld games and thief the  dark project System Shock was confirmed  late last year after a logo for the game  was leaked as of now we don't really  know much about this sequel studio  hasn't shown any gameplay or announced a  release window but when we hear more  you'll be the first to know  you